- Alright, I'm really excited about Jexi.
So you play a guy whose life
is taken over by his phone right?
- [Adam] Yeah.
- Are you addicted to
your phone in real life?
- We all are people, don't
try to hide it, okay.
I'm a real addict.
- [Kelly] Really?
- Yeah, well, I think everybody,
I don't know how to drive anywhere.
- Oh, my husband--
- Like, if I don't get
directions from my phone
I don't go there.
- I know and it drives my husband nuts.
He's like "Why do you use your phone?
"You know, what if something
happens to your phone
"you're not even gonna know where to go!"
And I'm like, "I'll find it."
- Yeah.
- It'll find, it'll be there.
- You won't find it.
You won't find it.
- [Kelly] I am always on Waze.
- Me too, Waze.
And then like, I won't be
able to find my way home.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- Like literally, I'm going home
I'm at a place where I know where I'm at.
And then try to find my way home
I'm like I just gotta punch it into Waze.
'Cause what if I have
to spend two and half
more minutes more in the car?
I'd rather take 11 left, very
dangerous left hand turns.
- To get there.
- Just with ease.
- Just like (panicked yelling)
- Do you feel like you've
switched from childhood?
I feel like I knew phone numbers,
I knew addresses, I knew everything,
how to get anywhere when I was kid.
Like on my bike or walking or whatever.
Now like as an adult I am now a toddler
who knows none of that.
I don't know anyone's number.
I know my husbands.
- I don't, yeah, I
don't really know anyone
even my parents they don't
have a home phone anymore.
- [Kelly] 'Cause why?
- Yeah, no one does, landlines are dead.
- I know Archaic if you will.
- Like Bell, the Bell
company, they're pissed.
(laughing loudly)
- Jeff Bell or whoever that guy was.
He's bummed.
- Oh my god, y'all
don't have a home phone?
This is your mom?
- This is my mom and dad
right here by the way.
(crowd applauding)
- I was bragging on them backstage
'cause you did so awesome with this one,
he's so loved.
- Oh, thank you.
- Literally no one has gotten
that kind of applause yet, that's insane.
- Oh I paid them.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Good mom, see.
- Yup.
- So wait, you and your family recently,
you celebrated Adam DeVine day?
- Yeah, yeah. I shot my Netflix special
"Adam DeVine's Best Time Of Our Lives"
On, one person saw it cool.
(audience laughing)
- You were supposed to applaud there.
But they gave me, the mayor
gave me my own day in Omaha.
- What, that's cool!
- Yeah, cool.
- Oh my god.
- Yeah.
- I didn't get a day.
- You'll get a key.
You'll get something better than a day.
- [Kelly] I got a key, I want a day.
- I thought it was a day every year.
I thought every November
10th I'm getting it.
That's what I was telling people.
I relooked at the plague they gave me.
Just the one day.
- [Kelly] It's just the one day.
(all laugh)
- They're like, We're gonna
do something else next year.
- I think you have to
like discover a world,
or lead the country. (laughs)
All right I'm sure you all saw
Adam preform at the
Emmy awards last month.
It was incredible.
- [Adam] Well, thank you.
- [Kelly] Here's the funny part of it.
You got, you were under attack for,
first of all the greatest thing ever.
- I was under attack guys, I was attacked.
Well, they, Variety
said that I lip synced.
- Which by the way just means
that you're that bad ass.
- Well thank you for that.
But I sang that and I was pretty bummed.
- No I know, that's happened to me before.
I was like, I wanted to
call this lady named Lisa.
- I feel like any real
singer would have been like,
"oh no he sang that, you could tell."
- No, but that's what I'm saying,
it was actually a good thing.
I got so mad about it when
it happened to me years ago,
'cause I was like, "I just
worked my tail off on stage!"
And somebody said that, and
then everybody was like,
well maybe that just
means you did it so well
that people thought it had to have been--
- Well by the way,
if I'm ever asked to do
anything like that again,
I'm more than happy to lip sync.
That would take away
like all the pressure.
- Oh my gosh right and running around?
- Yeah it's like, a full day
of rehearsal the day before
and I'm just like trying
to learn dance moves.
And I'm not a real dancer or singer.
So I'm like not in my wheel--
- But that's what makes it awesome.
- It's what makes it fun.
- That's the best part.
- Where, I feel like
me out there doing that
it gives like, anyone hope.
(audience laugh)
- That's how I feel.
- It's just a guy out
there whose mute, he's like
(murmurs) maybe I could do that?
- [Kelly] He can't even
talk but he's like,
"I can get this!"
- "I wanna be a singer!"
- [Kelly] Alright well my favorite part,
was the giant Meryl Streep head.
It was a little psychotic
and she had no soul
'cause the eyes were gone.
But it was, the eyes were dark.
They were dark, but that
was my favorite part.
- [Adam] Weirdly, that was
Meryl Streep doing that.
(audience laughing)
- She does everything, she's
also an amazing juggler.
- She also can turn her eyes black.
- Yeah.
- She's talented.
- She's really talented.
- This is also something
I found out about you
that I did not know,
so you were in like a horrific
accident when you were a kid,
and it was, a truck hit you.
- Cement truck.
- A big cement truck.
- A bigger kind of truck.
- Dang!
- Not a Ford, not a little --
- [Kelly] Not even like an F150.
- Not an F150, not an F250.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, how did it --
- Bigger.
- How did it even,
How did that shape you?
Because you've gotta be,
you had to have so much--
- Mangled me.
(audience laugh)
- I was a very weird
shape after that, obtuse.
- All the geometric angles.
- A lot of weird angles.
- No I meant like (laughs) not physically!
I meant like mentally and emotionally.
That had to kind of change things.
You're funny.
- For sure.
(all laugh)
Well, no, absolutely, I think like yeah,
I like what I'm now
I'm like happy that it happened
because I don't think I'd
be doing what I'm doing
and it also, it like
gave me the confidence,
'cause I had to re learn how to walk,
I couldn't walk it was a two year process
to gain the strength back in my legs
and learn how to walk again.
And I lost all the muscle and I shattered
everything from my knees down.
So I had to like, fully relearn.
That's like really hard to do, turns out.
- Turns out!
- You think on paper, yeah!
One step, another step, you got it!
You figured it out when you were one
you can figure it out now.
It was very hard and so now I'm like,
I can do anything when I can't.
But I have that confidence.
- But you can, that's what I love about,
I think that a lot of
like creative people have odd things
that happen to them in childhood
that are horrible or whatever
'cause it kind of shapes you
and it makes you this creative person.
You can, make fun of
yourself, self deprecation.
- For sure.
- [Kelly] And even have like, no shame.
You're just like "I'm in it, why not?"
- And also like, I feel
like, my parents being here,
what's up mom and dad.
Angle on them.
And they also then were like,
'cause it's a blue collar
family from the Midwest
we didn't know anybody in Hollywood,
we didn't know that you
could even like truly make
a career out of this.
If that's what you call this.
It's a career mom!
- It's a real job!
- Then they got on
board and they were like
"Whatever you wanna do, you didn't die!
"Whatever you wanna do!"
- See this all worked out in the end!
- "You can be a doctor!"
And I'm like "what about
a stand up comedian?"
And they're like, "okay."
- [Kelly] Sure, that one too.
- "If that's what you wanna be." (laughs)
- So, what do you think, 'cause I always,
people always ask me this question and
I always kinda start questioning myself
later on that day,
but what do you think, if
that wouldn't have happened,
do you think that this
would have been your path?
Or do you think you would
have done something else?
- For sure, I would be
like a cool wedding DJ.
(all laugh loudly)
And I would do a lot of bad beat boxing,
you know like, Jacob and
Linda, getting hitched!
(imitates beat box)
Radio edit!
- I would have been the wedding singer!
I would have been cool with it!
Wedding receptions are the best.
- I wanna go right to like,
the good part of the
wedding is like the vows,
and then people cry and then
immediately start drinking.
That's what I want my wedding to be.
- I eloped, and was like "bye!"
- I'm gonna give everyone
camel backs filled with wine,
or whatever type of booze.
(cheers)
So they could just suck their
way through the wedding!
- I would come to your wedding!
- You're invited!
- You have to sing though,
you do have to sing.
- You weren't a wedding singer though,
but you did have an interesting job that
we actually have in common.
You were a tele-marketer.
- Oh you were a tele-marketer too?
- I was.
- Oh dang!
- I was a tele-marketer
for the comedy club
I cocktail waitress for
on the weekends.
- Oh you did that.
- So I got to kind of
sell them free tickets,
but there's a two drink minimum.
- I did a lot of weird,
I sold Time Life books
over the phone, I sold steaks.
- Steaks, Omaha Steaks.
- Omaha Steaks is where I worked.
- Yeah.
- It would be a lot of me--
- Is that like, how you
sell that, mine was easier.
- I would call and my main
thing, it's so stupid,
I would take a piece of paper,
and this was like my closer,
I would wiggle the piece of paper
in front of my face which
is where the headset was
and then I go, "sorry,
excuse me, my managers here.
"What's that, no I
can't, really, no, what?"
And then I get back and I'm like,
"I'm so sorry, I can't
believe this is happening,
"But this just came in from upstairs,"
One floor building.
"This came in from upstairs,
"We're gonna cut the price
of those filets by half."
(audience laughing)
"I can't believe we're doing this!"
And then people were like (gasps).
Everyone wants a deal.
- Oh my god! (laughing)
- And then you just say,
"now, does that Visa
start with a four?"
They all do.
"Yes, and what are those
other numbers a one?"
(audience laughing)
- Oh my god you are a liar!
You're good at it!
- Got 'em and that paid
for my 1993 Cavalier.
- Yeah mine was a ford.
- Salvage title.
- (laughs) Love him!